dès ce matin
les habitants de moscou et de nombreuses
régions russes
devons avoir à rester chez eux c'est le
cas pour les plus de 60 ans les
commerces non essentiels vont également
fermer les restaurants les lieux publics
salle de spectacle et théâtres les
musées les entreprises vont devoir
maintenir en télétravail 3 30% de leurs
leurs employés de leurs employés et
voilà pour voilà pour l'essentiel de ces
mesures décidées alors que la russie
connaît une nouvelle vague extrêmement
graves de que vide marqué par des
nombres de morts en
ascension constante plus de 1000 par
jour ce qui est ce qui est énorme
moi ce que je constate moi qui résident
en russie c'est que il ya plusieurs
phénomènes d'abord un non respect sinon
flagrant des mesures barrières tous ces
derniers mois dans le métro que je prend
quotidiennement
les trois quarts des gens ne porte pas
de masque le porte mal dans les magasins
dans les restaurants pas de mesures
barrières particulière les gens portent
pas de masque dans les endroits où il ya
beaucoup de
population où les gens se pressent les
cafés les bars tout ça les gens sont
ensemble sans crainte sans voilà sans
aucune précaution et là bas coûté la
population malheureusement en paye le
prix le deuxième phénomène extrêmement
grave important et qui motive ces
mesures décidées par les autorités
russes c'est le taux extrêmement faible
de vaccination dans le pays à peine plus
de 30% ce qui est vraiment extrêmement
bas quand on le compare au niveau par
exemple d'aider des pays d'europe
occidentale et en premier lieu de deux
la france donc les mesures qui sont
décidées sont des sons des mises en
place pour inciter
les gens à aller se faire se faire
vacciner
et à surmonter leurs réticences parce
que je constate c'est que les gens
continuent d'avoir et autour de moi je
le vois parmi mes amis russes continuent
à avoir une grande méfiance à l'égard du
vaccin du laxisme unique met en cause la
parole gouvernementale c'est pas faute
de 2,2 de la part de vladimir poutine
d'avoir à plusieurs reprises ces
derniers mois un site est appelé les
russes à aller se faire vacciner mais
malgré tout les gens les gens ont peur
les gens disent que le vaccin n'a pas
été suffisamment expérimenté que tout ça
est une vaste machination c'est ce qu'on
entend parfois bref
toutes ces craintes y compris des
invocations complotisme
d'ailleurs le plus souvent venus de
l'extérieur des frontières tout ça on
l'entend
et le but du jeu cette fois ci c'est
vraiment de ce n'est là
la larme pour que les gens aillent se
faire vacciner on va voir si c'est le
cas
pour l'instant et ça a été la position
constante des autorités russes depuis le
début de la pandémie c'est de ne pas
nuire à l'économie donc pas de mesures
de lock down confinement comme on dit
ici de qui risquerait de mettre en péril
l'économie et a surtout à comment dira
encore précarisés la situation des
russes dont la majorité
vivent très mal et qui ferait encore
plus mal si l'économie devait s'arrêter
ça le vladimir poutine et son
gouvernement n'ont
hautement conscience et ce matin encore
le porte parole du kremlin dmitri peskov
a exclu tout confinement tout
confinement des rustauds confinement
complet de la population russe je me
rappel seuls les plus de 60 ans sont
enjoints à rester chez eux jusqu'au mois
de février prochain une autre constante
ici c'est la position du gouvernement
russe à responsabiliser les gouverneurs
de province et donc à se dégager au
niveau central d'une forme de
responsabilité vis-à-vis de la situation
et les mesures qui sont prises donc il
ya des directives générales et puis
après c'est à chaque autorités
régionales les gouverneurs dans ce pays
qui est très vaste savez neuf fuseaux
horaires c'est à chacun de mettre en
oeuvre les cils et les mesures de
prévention
selon les situations locales les
situations sont très diverses parce que
est à la fois des centres urbains comme
moscou et saint pétersbourg qui sont les
deux villes les plus touchées et puis il
ya dans cet entre deux régions y compris
un bâtiment en extrême orient russe
mégane à dos des régions voilà il ya il
n'y a que quelques dizaines d'habitants
par par
centaines de kilomètres carrés et est là
évidemment les situations la situation
est tout autre
ça ça a créé
certaines formes de d'inquiétude on a vu
les gens ici des deux essayez par
exemple de ponts c'est que les
réservations par exemple pour la turquie
pour l'egypte enfin les pays où les
russes peuvent voyager on a vu le nombre
de réservations
monter sur cette période de d'un peu
plus d'une semaine à priori puisque des
mesures dans la ville de moscou tout au
moins ont été décidés à partie à partir
de ce matin et jusqu'au jusqu'au 10
novembre donc les gens essayer de
quitter la capitale dalé de prendre des
congés dans d'autres villes ce qui a
d'ailleurs amené saint pétersbourg où
les gens à vers lesquels la grande cité
du nord du pays dans lesquels les gens
s'apprêtait à se diriger ce qui a incité
les autorités saint pétersbourg a elle
aussi mettre en mesure d mettre en
oeuvre des mesures plus restrictives
pourrait pour éviter un afflux de un
afflux de c'est en quelque sorte de
touristes circonstances et donc chacun a
essayé de de s'arranger c'est très
perturbant pour la vie quotidienne pour
les écoles fermées
les restaurants fermés chacun se demande
comment est-ce qu'il va s'organiser
encore une fois une fille hormis une
courte période début de la pandémie en
avril 2020 il n'y a jamais vraiment de
confinement de mesures restrictives et
surtout pas cette atmosphère je dirais
un peu obsessionnel comme on l'a connu
en france autour du coc vide voilà ici
les gens ont été préservés
avec maintenant bien le coup et les
conséquences que l'on constate avec 7
cette augmentation assez terrifiante de
la pandémie
[Musique]
on